[Music]
welcome everybody hello as all going
good to see you all here thanks for
coming to this talk specifically there's
many many talks going on at the same
time so I'm really really pleased to see
you here so thank you for coming and I
hope you really get a good chance to
enjoy all of next particularly upstairs
on the third floor the Showcase which we
spent the last three or four months
building and we think it's a lot of fun
so read lovely to see you up there you
have any questions I'll be crawling
around there generally and if you kind
of get stuck need help if you see
anybody wearing a jacket like this with
developer relations on the back you can
come up and ask us questions and we will
make sure that you get the mansard for
you okay so welcome thank you for coming
we're going to talk about designing
secure user experience into your
products and my name is Mandy wakes I'm
a developer advocate I work on Google
Cloud Google cloud platform specifically
now we have this more wider umbrella and
you can find me on twitter at at tek
gwil ok so please feel free to tweet me
if you have any questions that we don't
answer today so yeah how many of you
would develop oh wow just listen okay
how many of you and not developers okay
interesting that's the other half now
some people didn't put their hands up
which is interesting okay so we're just
going to have more of a developer focus
generally but we are going to talk about
some UX stuff up front before we get to
the more detailed things that developers
will care about the agenda is something
like this I don't normally do agendas so
building good security X is where we
start we're going to go through that
then we're going to get something called
google safebrowsing how many of you have
heard of google safebrowsing before
excellent okay most of you have used it
most of you have used it without
probably no new using it we'll get into
that shortly okay so security UX we are
in a world where security is vital we
need to build security into everything
that we build it should never really be
an after fall but it has for a long time
bin
so we want to kind of talk about how how
this works within the context of Google
not necessary in the context of building
products generally but more than all the
experience of we've we've gained over
the years and also look at the tools
that we provide that can actually help
you build secure UX into your products
ok so this is a bridge this is a bridge
is a good picture of a bridge it's got
guardrails guardrail always protect
pedestrians from and probably cyclists
as well from the traffic on one side and
the water on the other they do a very
effective job of that as well and as do
these things as well these interstitials
these warnings that pop up that people
see on a regular basis these effectively
protect these people from danger ahead
things like fishing or malware or
unwanted software generally these things
are really powerful really useful but
they are hard to design and heart are
very hard to get right and so I'd like
to talk today about some of that and how
it works the wardings ultimately
essentially convince users to stop doing
what they're doing ok you know how easy
that is right to convince people to stop
doing what they're doing no I will do
this I will do this and it's a fine art
it's trade-offs it's checks and balances
there's a lot of things involved in
getting this right and there's a lot of
research involved hoping that we can
show you some of that so why would you
use a ignore a warning right no one we
just saw on the previous page why would
why would we you ignore that or more
importantly the bigger one which is like
this you see these why would you ignore
it and there are generally three main
reasons why people might ignore it there
are more these are the ones we finger
important today in this talk all of them
are important and all of them should be
given due consideration but the ones we
kind of really wants a kinda mentions
are they are the fact that some bins are
Cecil right that will likely be
interrupting what a user is doing
something they want to actually get done
and it may well be that they're under
kind of
should I get it done as well I said you
want to move ahead they want to go to
visit decide that they visited regularly
maybe not very long ago they want to
download the software because they know
to the soccer is good but these warnings
are coming up telling them to stop
that's one reason why people might
ignore it also the situation may be
highly technical and again this kind of
plays into what we do as people we
develop products not necessarily the
situation itself even highly technical
situations can be explained in a way
that people can understand we will go
into that in more detail very shortly
sometimes a rich just isn't clear it may
be something you do on a regular basis
right you know you go to this fight
every day and today is broken for some
reason today something up it just big
red sign and you don't think that's
right so I don't know what the risk is I
don't really care and when they click on
this and go ahead anyway so there's some
of the reasons that people may ignore
warnings like that there are some
additional challenges as well to come up
we really by developing these into see
shows and you yourself in the products
you don't want to stop people do the
right thing do something that they
should be entitled to do but we also
need to make sure that we keep a very
low false positive rate as well we need
to gain some trust into the system if we
just fail all of the time and are
unreliable in that a trusted advisor
then we lose people's mind share their
likely certain have less trusting this
in future when we display these kind of
messages and ultimately this slide is
here to show device and pick because the
dungeon pick is funny and it's cute and
this time of day you need something like
that so uplift you because it's that
kind of day we just over the hump reside
llanishen we need ranch and pigs and
ultimately it's reasonably true that
given a choice between dogs and pigs and
security users will pick knowledge and
pigs now again that's not too kind of
undermine security in anyways dancing
pigs are interesting but sometimes going
to the dogs and pigs may be dangerous so
let's not worry too much about the
balancing pigs I don't know they are
dangerous but it could be alright so
that was a quote made with Dalton
so I can be defined at Princeton I just
moved to America by the way / for
monthly a mid-tier performance is
wonderful I like it madam in San
Francisco which is where we are today
exchange comprehension so we talked
about we've set the scene for secure UX
some of the key components of that and
the key considerations are around
comprehension so we're going to talk
about comprehension first before we move
on to the next stage so what the
computation mean comprehension
ultimately means the users understand
what's going on okay so they see these
warnings maybe other information you
provide as part of your user interface I
just based around security and when
people read this information when they
see these interstitials that kind of
thing or pop-ups they understand exactly
what's going on this is key if it's
confusing people want guide to
understanding and won't be able to make
it do the right thing we want them to do
the right thing little the by that
shortly as well so comprehension is I'm
kind of interested in this sentence
because I rigidly wrote it and I kind of
changed my mind on it but I wanted to
leave it there anyway the user should be
able to make an informed decision now
ultimately really with these things we
don't want them to make a decision we
want them to make do the thing that we
want them to do so this shouldn't really
be a decision but we wanted to make the
right choice we want them to actually
say they want me to skip going ahead to
the website data want me to download the
software I'm going to do it but
ultimately it does play into that
because you have to kind of balance the
odds right you have to take all of the
information is available and make a
decision okay will I click on this back
to safety button or what I'd find a way
to circumvent it somehow by may be
digging into these menus which may give
me an option to go forward which is
really what I want to do so it's kind of
interesting is that it's a real
trade-off in a real balancing game
ultimately when it comes down to is the
user should be able to understand the
exact source of the threat they should
be at understand exactly what's at risk
they're about to send their password to
somebody they don't trust
because of some Christians camp they
also need to understand the likelihood
of it being false false positive warning
which may well undermine the whole
system they used to get imported false
positives and ultimately that may mean
that they have very little trust in the
system so Microsoft have a or some time
ago did a study and Accord it neat and
neat is based on these principles here
we would like to simultaneously
accomplish these things will them
together music you see some of them
there's a bit of a tension between some
of them we wanted to be presented in the
non-technical language we can't make any
assumptions about people's technical
background you do people here may well
be a bleep burst with all of the kinds
of technology that's out there and we
can present you with stack faces and
such life and you'll save as a snack
tray so like this one with the Java
stack traces about that long like I
planned anything really point it which
is quite interesting we want to present
it in a non technical way reading level
should be fairly low we want to make
sure that everybody can read it and
again what it briefly a native English
speaker not everybody is old or older
like we are like I am at least we want
me to be as brief as possible as well we
don't want people to have to read for
reams and reams and reams of what though
be existent find out what's going on we
want to be very specific about the risk
as well and we want to provide enough
information and as you can see there's
some tension there right be as brief as
possible providing enough information
okay you gotta get that balance right
another one would be being very specific
about the risk for not using any kind of
technical jargon that also makes it more
complicated for this intentions here you
do your best and you do some trade-offs
and the talk yet about some of that more
surely hang ordering yogurt was one
question with it warming the keynote
today some people say with Matt okay I
interesting okay
I was fighting fires out in the showcase
for didn't get to see it but I will
watch it later all right kind of where
re what we don't aim to do we are not
trying to accomplish providing some kind
of complete description of the issue
that would probably go back to what we
looked something to the side some of the
things we want to accomplish two
millennia slee one thing is we don't
want to do is actually provide a
complete description of the issue we're
not providing information for software
engineers again we can do and often at
Google we see things that other people
don't see slight traces and such like
when things go wrong which is quite
interested in useful for us engineers
and sometimes it probably is a bit
frustrating for software engineers to
see these kinds of interesting so as I
say mumbling no more about what happened
and so we can do that we can hand with
that we can provide learn more links or
advanced drop downs that people can use
to actually find out more about what's
going on drill deeper into the property
and there's also things I developer
tools in such like that can actually
help you understand better what went on
there you could be using chrome web
tools and such like to find exactly what
happened underneath the hood so that's
where we end up we end up with these
kind of lovely radiance officials and
the black color is is a very strong one
maybe one day I can ask Allison why we
choose have this kind of very strong red
color but it does provide that kind of
warning do not go ahead this is
dangerous it's hard to ignore so we're
gonna talk more about you shortly
because these come from a product called
safe browsing and we're going to talk in
detail by that very shortly and the next
thing is beyond comprehension we need to
think about adherents adherence there if
the game is making sure people do the
right thing which is the thing we want
them to do so adherence is users do what
you want okay that's important okay
we're not putting these things up for a
laugh we're putting them up because it
is serious we've detected some kind of
threat ahead and we'll look at
confidence levels in such right shortly
but we really want them to do the thing
with send to do okay so we can measure
that
let's talk about exactly how we can make
it more likely the people will do the
thing that you want so opinionated
design is the first tenant around that
we need to design to be reasonably
opinionated about what we want you to do
is a user so we've had great success
when user interface provides things like
very clear instructions it provides an
attractive preferred choice again the
way we present it may play into this it
provides an unattractive other choice or
it provides no other choice at all okay
being bone strongly opinionated we may
say this file is infected with a virus
we are not going to let you download it
okay and ash that's an extremely
opinionated view of the world and often
you don't go that far but you may be
prepared to if you are very very
confident that reflect is there and real
the very act of downloading an infected
file with your system can automatically
detect your system let's be fair about
that so looking at this one this is the
current download interspecies a pop-up
we see nowadays we try to download a
file just infected with something and we
protected that it's infected we will
tell you to decide it we said the file
is dangerous so chrome has blocked it
and when you click on list click on the
down arrow you you find out learn more
he's only seen ignore my warning and go
ahead you see learn more I wishing tell
you more about it but we really do not
want you to download it okay do you
think about why we're doing this we want
to reduce infection rates we want to
reduce infected sites across the globe
we want to make the internet a safer
place for everybody and this is where
tools such as safe browsing playing so
here's an example I'm going to dive into
some older older content that's been
around for a while so somebody's screen
is going to be fairly old but I think
they're still interesting because they
show some of the ways we've progressed
over the way we see this discovered a
security that user experience and you
probably all at some point in your life
unless you're extremely young seeing
this one which is the HTTPS warning from
chrome ok so chrome
2014 ish would have displayed if
certificate if this certificate this
message if ssl wasn't working correctly
if it seemed that you were trying to go
to a site that didn't have a pilot
certificate and we're not very
opinionated here we say proceed anyway
back to safely so you think this is
opinionated who things is non
opinionated okay right so it's not
really opinionated we offer two choices
the first one is proceed anyway okay job
wings back to safety now there is some
background around HTTPS warnings you
should probably now we're going to get
to shortly but really we're not being
very opinionated we should really want
them to go back to safety they may have
more information about what's going on
than we do but we do really want them to
go back to safety but we've also been
this option to proceed anyway we have a
now help me understand link which may
actually clarify the issue you look at
that today that all we had today within
chrome and this is the HCBS morning
today your connection is not private
attackers might be trying to steal your
information from whatever they may be
trying to get your passwords and your
messages and your credit card you say
important stuff you don't want to give
this stuff away to people I'm the perc
kind of person who actually cares labels
offer boxes and envelopes and kind of
spreads them more compressible and
frozen the wades such a way that no
biggie never read them so nobody can get
any kind of information from me you do
not want to share your password and your
solution with social security number in
the clear so we really want you to not
do this you may have additional
information as I say that may lead you
to want to go ahead and do it so we have
a big blue back to safety button so now
we don't want to be a red button
obviously because it's not going to be
helpful here so nice blue one a nice
color that people will actually respond
to if they need to find out more they
can go to advanced and if they need to
if they had other information that we in
the world they can choose to proceed so
that's opinionated very opinionated
so a couple more examples and these are
older interstitials or pop-ups that
we've had in the past the first one is
somewhat more there are less opinionated
in the first one both are a little bit
old line opinionated but you can see the
first one important point here adherence
can be measured okay you have control
you can understand what users do when
they when they see these pop-ups what
did they do what stupid they take did
they choose to keep the file did they
choose to discard the file we can
measure that and that's what's called
adherence how many people decided to
actually heed your warning so this case
with the first one seventy-two percent
of people decided okay fair cop I'm
British by the way so speak please Chloe
colloquialisms like bare [ __ ] mate
seventy-two percent people actually
decided to discard in the first case
which isn't very high it's not bad but
it's not not very want to be we want to
be a hundred percent if possible the
bottom one is better we're saying the
file is malicious we have a strong
opinion that this malicious we're not
saying it appeared malicious is angry
hey these things of malicious I don't
download it but we still offer a couple
of options ninety-three percent
adherence rate here so people did the
right thing people did the thing that we
wanted them to do and much more
frequently than they did with the first
case oh sorry but now so it's changed
I'm sure somebody is editing my slides
when I'm talking or I just made last
minute changes that didn't come out
right aking that we will ignore this
slide this slide is a mistake but we
will get back to it very shortly right
okay war in petite as you can imagine
and you could experience issues it
particularly used Windows Windows 7 back
in the early days when it first launched
and you had to kind of like approve
everything you had so many pop-ups it's
unbelievable or maybe that was windows 8
and not sure but william petit how many
times have you had warning boutique
where the warning keeps popping up it
seems like the same one you're not quite
sure it is assumed
that it does seem to be annoying and
never Satan and doesn't seem to be
particularly relevant there is evidence
of warning patike but you have to be
careful and we have to think about this
and we'll try to get to the bottom that
shortly so this is again https warnings
looking at adherence from different
countries and i'll leave that user guess
which countries they are because i don't
know what them I do not know what TR is
for example and I should have checked
number of prior warning impressions so
basically the first time you see this
morning pop up around about 75 to
seventy-seven percent of people on
average would do the thing you wanted
them to do but after a while after five
birdies within a period of time people
get kind of fatigued by the whole
process and let dough much less likely
more significantly less likely in this
case around got chopped stands around
fifty percent are likely to follow your
instructions or follow your advice and
that's not a great situation but this
isn't just about warding fatigue is also
about many many different vectors
particularly around what type of threat
it is and how you present it so all
these things need consideration which is
why we're going to talk about
measurement very shortly and just to
kind of contrast that unwanted software
warnings okay this is different this is
different behavior so you WWF I'm once
and software so this is the same kind of
thing adherence is high to begin with
people generally don't want unwanted
software you know these things are just
annoying you didn't ask for it it's not
like your twine is blocking you from
doing some of you really want to do it's
just like a pop-up saying now no diff
okay so i'm not going to download that i
don't know what it is and you're
probably going to say ignore now i get
rid of delete whatever but at the same
time it's the zero that the first time
you're going to see it's around ninety
five percent but they should get more
and more than you're even more likely
not significantly but even more likely
to follow the instructions to discard it
so that's significant we've understand
the difference between show
hey Stacy GPS organs and showing them
with his software warnings so this all
comes back to measurement which we talk
about shortly so false alarms and repeat
mornings as well this is quite
interesting so slow chickens and sorry
for just one hour earlier we had to have
commissioned kittens in Google results
it's a rule of the company so each false
alarm reduces the credibility of a
warning system this is a fairly old ol
quote from a white paper slow kittens
and just to talk about that we found
that people don't respond favorably to
repeat warnings now we're talking about
repeat wounds are the same thing that's
clearly the same thing being repeated
over and over again if you do something
if you click on make a decision to do
something bae someone losing 50 shows we
should remember it for some period of
time okay but what's the ideal period of
time it should it be a day should it be
a week and it should be an hour before
we display that message again if you get
an ssl wall in and decide to continue
should we just remember that we ever
will always let you go there or should
we constantly remind you should we
constantly remind you every five minutes
because we respond to remind you every
day or every week and there's this whole
thing about regrets as well some people
regret that decision they decide to move
forward to go to a site that they don't
trust also downloads from malware that
they shouldn't met downloads and we do
regret the decision and you have these
things called the adherence rate which
is already talked about and also to
regret rates as well that's harder to
measure and I don't know a huge amount
of our depth so I mean just started
reading this my paper but if you are
interested in that come talk to me
afterwards but there is a sweet spot
here of about a week if we remember your
decision as a user for about a week and
then represent that again a week later
and that seems a bit be about the right
sweet spot in terms of getting it here
in flight and in terms of making sure
that people don't regret their decision
all right
so let's look at that measurement well I
kind of mentioned measurement quite a
lot so far and I'm not going to go into
huge because I want to get into the safe
browsing and talk by that I mean if you
came here to talk about safe browsing
specifically okay now good Mary so we're
going to quickly introduce and user that
and inviting you measurement measurement
is important and here's some
measurements again these go back a while
but I'm a really good document a good
presentation has been presented before
back in 2014 Kronus malware in for
seasonal useful it like this and again
it's strongly opinionated he has a go
back option as an advanced option our
confidence in this that the fact that
there's malware behind whatever you're
trying to do is extremely strong and
upwards all right my clock just reset
the company's is extremely strong so
we're really confident that what you're
trying to do is download malware we're
telling you that it's malware and people
twenty five percent of them nearly are
still choosing to perceive and actually
download that malware that's a little
bit scary we need to do better we should
always be aiming to get one hundred
percent adherence this is effectively
seventy-seven percent adherence if we
look at these and again comparing to
we're going to compare chrome and
firefox we see the old non-fatal ssl
wheel in chrome proceed anywhere anyway
or back to safety we have less
confidence about this i think it's a
little bit more than that upping the
graphic people have actually just added
a little bit but it's not that high it's
reasonable but it's not that high there
are many different reasons why an S a
sort of SSL certificate may be invalid
and it may not be a fret it maybe
there's a self-signed certificate for
example which means it doesn't fly back
into a root certificate so there are
many reasons why there may be problems
with ssl that we would flag as being
something problematic so we have less
confidence here and we found the
click-through rate will be around sixty
eight percent okay so sick
d % of people decided to proceed to the
fire anyway okay now what is it is it is
it the nature of the volume is the
problem or is it the way it's presented
or let's take a look at firefox firefox
at exactly the same time had this
interstitial this connection is
untrusted get me out of here you've all
seen this as well as we've use firefox
before get me out of here it's fairly
clear is very opinionated we have the
same deborah confidence though this is
still ssl there's nothing different
story using Firefox and Chrome but we
can see the click-through rate is now
down to thirty three percent okay so
this is important this is an important
measurement we have to improve on that
UVC a sixty-eight percent click through
your pretty sure you don't want them to
continue you need to fix that but only
by measuring it can you actually
understand how to fix it and what to do
what you need to change in the way you
message this the way you present it to
the user the only way you can fix that
is by measuring it so measurement is
ultimately the key to how is that
comprehension and adherence are you do
your AV system you maybe have different
versions of the interstitial and we've
done that many many times Allison are we
doing that kind of a/b testing currently
with a safe browsing yep so we do this
kind of a BS in all of the time and we
can get the statistics and what people
do we can work out and financing it
until we get it in fact you're right
click through rates adherence
effectively can vary based on a number
of different factors as we saw from the
Firefox Chrome comparison and there's
always room for improvement so do more
and more measurement is always going to
get you better results okay and you may
often see bad things worse things happen
when you go certain class which case you
can course-correct but you should never
be doing these things in isolation all
the mount to the time do a/b testing the
room all right okay so that's the first
part so we talked about secure ux
generally let's talk about google nicole
context recruit google we have a lot of
experience observing traffic we do it a
lot as
can you imagine and we do it in a lot of
different ways a lot of different types
of traffic so we have a lot of
experience when it comes to actually
building secure secure UX into our
products and again that's still ongoing
is always going to be an ongoing effort
based on the feedback that we get from
people's interactions with our products
and what we want to do is also talk
about something that actually aid you in
building more secure user experiments
into your products by using this
particular product called google
safebrowsing so it is a bit of a play on
Google sir vision which is ultimately
make the world's information safely
accessible okay so really doing a lot of
work up front to make it easier to
access information not only easier sorry
but also safer as well so making it
easier a bump on the mission making it
safely accessible is the other part of
it and we're going to talk about this in
more detail again these lovely red
science interstitials these come from
Safe Browsing so let's say you all
probably use Safe Browsing before
because you've all probably seen
warnings let s people you clicked on the
link maybe it was through from phishing
email hopefully not or maybe just a link
that turned up somewhere you clicked on
that hopefully these things don't set up
in search results we can get rid of
those but sometimes at some point in
time you will see these fundamental
seizures so that one is the chrome
interstitial that the other one is
chrome and Android okay Oh interesting
my speaker notes are here it's amazing I
didn't expect to see that so how does
google safebrowsing work so basically we
do crawl as you know as you can imagine
we call many many pages lots and lots of
pages every day tens of million sites
effectively are looking for harmful
content and we also have the notion of
we can get leads from other sources as
well there could also play into this and
what the result is we will build
blacklist some reputation databases that
can be used
as the backend for this Safe Browsing
API that is built into or built into
Chrome functionality in awesome to
Firefox and two other products as well
Safe Browsing surprisingly or maybe
unsurprisingly have you seen it a few
times is effectively protecting 1
billion people globally and about 1.1
whose last measurement we had is
probably higher now and ultimately every
day we crawl over 10 million URLs Chrome
extensions executables Android
applications every day so we have good
information about what's in thicker than
was not we are various algorithms can be
usefully text that kind of scams going
forward and also infected software we
detect around about 50,000 carpool sites
every week and safe browsing for Google
is built into most about products so we
look at Google Play if you are insulin
applications on uploading applications
into the Google Play Store save Browns
and will come into play will be looking
for malicious content being uploaded to
the Play Store and also through verify
apps it will also be used to protect
when you install from sources other than
google play as well it's built into
google search so there are is infected
now we're out there we even if we do
return the search page for it if we
aren't no its effects the infection will
display that most of the time we will
sort those out though Dougal add Google
eyes is extremely important because when
you see an ad and you click on it it
takes you to a link we don't want
natural sake user a patient may be a
phishing scam or providing mrs. content
and so this is built into as well it's
building as a gmail in terms of gmail it
protects users by identifying dangerous
links in email messages and it shows
volumes if users click on them also it
protects the Chrome Web Store from
potentially harmful waste mentions so
this is google safebrowsing built into
our products but we also have safe
browsers support for many of the
browsers are out there
as well so it protects things like
Google Chrome it protects Firefox Safari
and also chrome on Android ultimately
and kind of ruin the next slide it
protects the round about two billion
devices so actually a really
ridiculously high number two billion
devices are protected by safe browsing
through things like chrome firefox and
chrome on Android so we also show around
about 50 million Williams to use it on a
weekly basis so those red interstitials
you see appear around about over 50
million times a week we also provide
support for webmasters and also for
developers so we build in Safe Browsing
into safety net within Android and that
less mobile developers check URLs
against the Safe Browsing lists it's in
fact the actual same API disused by
chrome on Android and thousands of
developers and network administrators
use the safe safe browsing API to
protect their platforms and their users
so if you can imagine that tens of
thousands of science get hacked every
day to serve harmful content ultimately
& Safe Browsing ultimately notifies
webmasters and site owners that their
sites have been infected so we have this
notification process which you can sign
up for we have a link at the end we'll
show you how to get to that but
basically if your webmaster and you're
signed up for Google webmasters you can
get access to these notifications and
they will tell you if your sites are
hosting malicious content but ultimately
with great power or whatever that reach
comes great responsibility and thou
shalt users to provide the best
protection for you while being very
precise within our results so as you can
imagine google safebrowsing is likely to
be a target the people who are creating
these malicious this malicious content
these malicious sites are going to want
to try to find a way around our
detection systems effectively and there
are various different ways of doing that
which will
get now no ugly so here we see who the
lines are not very clear on these on my
screen so here we have something on the
internet some content means that maybe
this is a sign maybe it's a some kind of
content is being served and when google
safebrowsing comes to look at it it sees
that's okay there's no problems there
but when play we call her Jane over
there she goes so download the same
content she sees something completely
different QC malicious software this
could be a problem and there's various
in ways that attackers can actually hide
themselves from Google's detection one
of the most common is IP cloaking
effectively serving benign contents of
our detection systems but doing
something very different when somebody
else on the internet comes to actually
access that content then cybercriminal
generally don't spend too much time on
individual vulnerable it vulnerable is
they tend to move on to different
exploits very very quickly so you have
to really be ahead of the game there's
also things called malva tizen malware
being delivered through ads it's all
this whole notion of cloaking extends
beyond just IP addresses and our best
protect protection where possible is to
appear exactly like the end user traffic
wherever we can if we look like end user
traffic then they're this Audi section
systems will not be flagged as being a
detection system we will see the content
that ordinary users well so that's
something that's constantly ongoing
within safe safe browsing one story from
the trenches I add to or isn't he a
little bit more complicated to explain
so I'm going to stick with this one so
imagine you're downloading software
you're using a browser potentially to
download software the download is
complete we have to decide whether we
should flag the content as malicious or
not the browser will do certain things
up months it can have some level of
trust
sesay filetype this safe file type is
one is not likely to infect the system
and so we can say that's fine we will
download that we provide it to the user
they will be able to access then if it's
a potentially harmful file without them
we need to go to the next level which is
does it come from a trusted source line
up it becomes from a trusted source
that's fine great okay we know that
source we can trust it we can download
the file and provider to the user it was
an untrusted source we're still not
completely competent there's going to be
a problem here at that point we want to
pull in Safe Browsing send the contents
of safe browsing and have it designed
for us I said whether the content is
malicious at that point we can make a
decision was whether it's safe or
whether it's harmful okay in this case
with trusted source is important to note
to be even local somewhere on your file
system or it could be a white list of
domain or a trusted signer so that's
important here because what you could
potentially do we'll check out what you
could potentially do here is break that
chain if you can get the download
completed but then you clean boat some
JavaScript code you can actually make
the file appear on the file system and
then source it back to the user by a
JavaScript so they actually believe so
the browser actually believes that the
file was source from a local file system
so it's one of these trusted sources and
that way can now bypass the system
because as a trusted source and it would
end here so that's a real problem and
that's the kind of addiction issues that
we have to deal with and harmful
javascript can cause potential issues
when it comes to bypass in Safe Browsing
security also let's talk about
partnerships as well so safe browsing
data is very hard and take some
tremendous amount of resources most of
these challenges of scaling division
what we want to make sure our work and
have the biggest impact as possible okay
for that we need to work with other
people with third parties and we view
people on integration so we can't do it
alone and I mentioned earlier that we
have sources that can provide more input
into the list that we build so we
collaborate with partners both inside
and
side of Google and we also partner with
external companies to combat harmful
come content and protect users there are
three main tools that you can use to
protect your users so the first point is
we protect Network and content owners so
we can by using the safe route into the
network and content owners program you
can actually have us send you
notifications when we detect harmful
content on your network you'll be hosted
on your network and currently we have
around about this little bit of an old
number and maybe higher now roughly
around about 22,000 asos alternative
system numbers subscribed that's around
about forty percent of the packs of a
essence out there currently so gay thing
effectively uniquely identifies each
Network on the internet okay so we can
help there so we can help you understand
on your own networks whether you have
any kind of malicious content being
hosted and for help you to avoid
propagation hours at the rest of the
world or internally within your own
company also when it comes to webmasters
again we mentioned this already with
Google webmasters you can sign up by the
security console for notifications we
can set your sights for malicious
content it's very very simple very easy
to get started with you just have to
verify that you own the property and
then we can provide information like
this and we're doing this because we
want to minimize the impacts of all
users out there on the internet so we
can help you as you understand your data
issues on your own science as ocean is
reaching me powerful as well okay so
that sends out around about seven
hundred fifty dollars and notifications
per year and it reduces the duration off
sites being infected by around about
sixty percent which is really important
so this kind of reduces the need for
Safe Browsing to actually display
interstitials like we've seen before
because we're reducing the infection
rates and also eighty percent successful
clean out clean up so these sites are
infected many of them get cleaned up
very very quickly without those
notifications they would not have been
aware that they were infected until
maybe they had some other kind of report
that they were infected so webmasters
really helps with that
we also for developers we have api and
api so you can build into your own code
and so this is where we going to get a
little bit deeper into the technical
aspects of this so the first one is the
lookup api the lookup api is used
basically to detect malicious content
detect content stored urls and give you
a report back as to what the threat was
seen it's very simple to use but stores
and downsides one downside is we learn
about new URLs you may not want us to
share those URLs with us let me see the
look up volume you can't do that many
lookups but it's kind of reg limited
around that and it's also a little bit
higher latency so around about 150
millisecond latency on average that
would play into user experience too it
would if you had to check every URL it
would add 150 millisecond latency by
accruing the Safe Browsing API there's
also di enjoyed lookup API as well again
this is ideal for mobile applications we
have a link for this at the end how to
get started it provides significant
bandwidth savings in the fact you don't
have to actually go all the way to
google to do it it preserves privacy
because you do not need to send URL to
Google you guys to make that detection
successful and is used by Android Chrome
today the other thing is a combination
of the lookup API which we talked about
yeah and something called the update API
this scales extremely well we're going
to show you a demo de sorte lee it
preserves privacy again we do not need
to send urls to google is used by the
major browsers including firefox and
chrome it does require client code from
those three developers so that's great
right because you like writing code okay
there are some links here on how to get
started for all three of those the first
one is the safe lands in b4 lookup API
documentation on developer.android.com /
training we have an index page on safe
browsing and also for the update a PMI
we have the similar documentation and
these links are at the end of the slide
and you will get access
the slides so don't worry about taking
notes of them now and if you do want to
know in the meantime you can always
tweet me in our continued to you so
let's go into a quick demo how are we
doing 60 minutes okay can we switch to
the demo oh I was gone to sleep all
right okay I'm an anime fan I make no
apologies for that all right okay so
what we're going to do here we will make
a quick access to the API we have the
site Belgian API anybody can access it
if you have a Google cloud platform
project you will need an API key for
this and to make things easier so I
don't show the API key i'll turn it into
a variable so i'll be using the API keys
are variable and not actually explain my
API key so Sony doesn't show up in the
video ok so what we can do is the usual
stuff right we can use a kill command to
send a message from api and we're going
to use this one i will walk for it I'm
hoping you can all see that very clearly
well then maybe which doesn't need to be
bigger even ok hopefully you can all see
that so basically we're just using the
curl command we're set in the header
we're setting content types of the
application Jason we're providing a body
and using the minus minus data flag this
is provided for a file in this case does
get symbol SB malware Jason and we're
going to send it to the API we're
providing as one parameters to the
argument sort of freight matches find
API endpoint the API key which is as I
said it's specified in an environment
variable ok so that's fairly
straightforward we can just hit that and
we will get back through very quickly a
message saying we detectives from
malware okay that's been easy right ok
very easy to do you can use standard a
standard rest libraries to build that
kind of query and you can send multiple
URLs at any given time to do a pnsu way
you can i call I'm sure absolutely
100 so let's have a quick look at what
that file was and what we actually sinks
at the API and will this be now where we
move this up come on okay should we
provide your metadata this is specific
to your company it doesn't identify you
but it does help you look in the audit
logs so effectively a metadata client ID
and client version and then some
information about what we want to look
up we're providing free threat entries
here one is going to well all three of
them are going through something called
test safe browsing to appspot com which
is an app engine application that
simulates frets one thing we really
don't want to do is kind of use real
life threats in the demo that's not a
good thing to do particularly this could
be on video so we had this set up and is
really really powerful really really
useful if you go for test browsing tests
a test see grounds into a sport common
is phone you see some interesting stuff
let's have a quick look at it I can find
my browser window excuse run away
and we make that bigger so you can go
here and you can use this for testing
generally you don't want to kind of send
lots and lots of traffic to this it's
not designed for that but you can't test
your your algorithms your code and just
like instantly so we can actually send a
fishing morning a malware warning
unwanted software warning link these are
three things we talked about earlier so
we can just simply click on this link
and it will see the big red sign in real
life okay so that's something we can use
the testing is what we use in the demo
today okay so go back to here so we've
specified free threat interests here
there are all urls will talk about what
the differences between a URL and the
other options we can use shortly we're
also saying we're looking for malware
we're also especially find a platform
we're looking for windows specifically
and we're specifying at the entry type
so we're going to provide our URLs
that's what we need to do to better do a
query so we provide that file we pass it
into the coil command or we provide one
of this information as a JSON objects
and send it to the API by RS call via
some kind of library that's really
straightforward and if we go back to
here we can do this for others as well
we're all so we have one set up for
fishing as well maybe not oh I I can't
build a word fishing I've spent the last
five days when spoiled award mission I
can't listen up that second page and so
now at this time we're looking for prek
type social engineering on a linux
platform and dr l w we've found phishing
attacks on is the one we saw earlier on
the test a proud inside quick mention of
cash duration as well we would like you
very much to understand that you can't
keep making the same call over and over
again and any kind of api is often under
danger from tight loops people going is
this a threat is very
is a threat so what we do is provide
back a cash duration period we want you
to cash the result of this for five
minutes not asking about that about day
you are L 45 minutes so we provide
information in the response that will
help you understand how them you should
cash it for before you go and check on
that URL again okay you son license is
changing those five minutes you're going
to go back and visit at some point but
in the meantime we should cash in the
last one is young ones and software we
will just look at that one very very
quickly and that's very similar this
time we have a freight type detective
unwanted software and its platform type
of any platform and the URL is again the
test Safe Browsing application the rest
of the data is pretty much the same okay
so that's fairly straightforward but we
looked at the what we sent it earlier
and that was actually free URLs so two
of those it didn't detect issues with
because we were only specifically
looking for in this case malware there's
only picked up on the malware issue we
could actually spend that to look for
all three if we wanted to we could do
and I apologize my typing which is
actually peril I should probably wear
glasses by typing it's very hard to see
screen all right okay so now we've done
that we can save that and we can send
them our way one back again becoming the
history and now we get free results back
okay so we can see that all three of the
URLs reported issues as expected but
before when we were thinking and we're
looking for specific attacks and
specific approach you can specify all of
the frets if you want to and they're
saved a platform type as well you can
specially not specify multiple platform
types the other part as well as the
update API which we talked about in the
slides mostly but i'll show it now to
save time and we provide a go client
library for this is effectively a
reference implementation of a library
that you can use so you can build on
this you can use as an example you can
actually write your own code in a
different language but on github we
provide a doe client library that you
can use and that's what I'm going to use
now so the first thing to do is to i'm
just going to clear my screen first bear
with me so we're going to install what
is known as SP server if you go to the
safe browsing github com google / a
browser and you'll find all of the code
there so i'm going to hit return now and
that's already installed so we didn't
actually saw your son's up you saw
netting prices in this demo all day what
we can do now is use a one DSP server
command and yes be server command will
run a local proxy to the Safe Browsing
API for us and so and I'm going to use
my history to make it easier to type all
this in we're going to run it from the
go path bin directory where the
built file was installed we're going to
specify the API key again as we did
before rule thing especially by a part
of a database in this case / 10 / s bdb
I wouldn't recommend using / temps a
store this data but for the purpose of
this demo it means I don't have to worry
about sticking it somewhere that I have
may have a pseudo for and also we can
specify a server address field port 8080
on localhost and so we run is now it
will look at the database initially
looked at the database and said it's
stale and now it's healthy what's going
on here and leave the hood we specify
the data database we didn't do that
before were to look up but effectively
what we're doing here is pulling down
those lists those black this we had
before reputation asst and pulling them
down locally in cash them locally so now
what we can do is we can make look up
calls against your local database now
the thing is about this is that we are
not storing the URLs in the database we
are storing hashes of the URLs so
effectively what we do is we go for a
process of Tanana Cronulla canonicalize
in that the urls then hashing urls and
in taking the first ball bites at that
hash and using that as a look up so when
we do lookups locally we're actually
doing them in a much different ways we
would do we were sending URLs to the API
now when we send in a URL to the API
itself directly it's still doing the
same thing for us the databases that are
stored on Safe Browsing are all hashes
and what we do is when we receive the
URL ways we convert into the hash and
then we compare that to the stored list
and if it's of you what we do for the
lookup for the update API is pulling up
this down locally so we can make calls
against it locally ok so we never had to
send those URLs to Google we never had
to make additional calls to google to
get the results back we have lower
latency as well ok so I'm not going to
go into that so I'm running out of trans
long as I quickly go back to my slides
and wrap up opposes that I do talk about
if we go back to the fire to thank you
Oh wonderful all right ok so we won't
Bruce honest we saw most of these fret
types malware social social engineering
I'm what
we're unspecified wreck types others as
well different platforms that we support
also hash URL and digest our fret
entries now URL was obvious we saw that
we sent a URL for the Safe Browsing API
but we've also specially by a hash as
well we know what the hashes we can send
that director to the API or to the
update version of the API and we can do
this thing for digest as well so we can
actually bypass finding URLs to anything
offensively so ultimately safe browsing
lists contain hashes effectively or at
least hash prefixes the first four by
subhash this dramatically reduces
bandwidth and makes life easier for us
this is a combination of the update and
rook our baby i once we had the SB
browser SB server that we saw earlier
running when we make calls against that
we are effectively making calls to a
bush local version of the lookup api
which your wife is update + look up look
up api so that looks like something like
this we have the hash prefix database
stored locally the database version is
sent back to the safe browsing and any
additions or removals are sent back to
the safe browsing local version of the
database and you saw that when we won't
prove the demo you saw at the database
of stale and in the database is healthy
and then it was pulling down updates to
make sure it had places versions of them
so this is the whole process by which
those hashes are arrived at we have this
canonicalization process which is seen
on the left here and also we that is
converted to these poor bite hashes
which are stored in the reputation
databases that's local whenever we want
to do a lookup we will send up send it
back the prefix back to safe browsing
and we will get back a list of results
that match and here's an example of
actual code written in go this is
similar to the code that's actually on
the github repo the one we showed
earlier so you can write your code very
easily and go but again if you want to
use other languages using a restful api
reversible library will work personally
for you
so yes an example using the FB server
that we looked at before the SB server
acts as a proxy effectively for the API
exposes a version locally or de Jason
look up API we can send requests for
that proxy and it will get hash look up
back home safe relation as needed
otherwise it will use is local database
and this is what the Jason look up looks
like we saw this earlier in the demo
code and here's a final kind of version
of what we actually typed in earlier see
when you get two slides you'll know how
to get starting with this I think this
is also in the github readme file and
just to quickly wrap up apologies for
the small sex again they multiply these
things are you make your size and use a
similar format for some reason
comprehension and adherents are the
cornerstones of very good security Rex
and what we've also talked about today
was google safebrowsing to get started
there are free links here the best thing
to do is actually just search for google
safebrowsing in google search and you'll
get access to these links again these
will be in the slides that are published
so you can go to safe browsing at
developers.google.com the webmaster
stuff is all linked there as well and
also you can sign up for the netops
thing through this uri here is what the
great issues of experience family but it
will ultimately get better
[Music]